the jurogan experience did you read the
email leaks do the emails from people
intercept and yeah all the the different
discussions that they had about their
concerns that they were responsible for
this through gain of function research
they applied for a grant to specifically
do a
to insert a furan cleavage site which is
that particular part of the virus that
that raised so much concern
yeah i mean look the thing is like if
this gets back this gets back to the
same thing i think we're dancing around
a little bit which is i don't know
sometimes what to do with this it's
highly suspicious
i think of this and sometimes the way i
think about my teenage kids they're not
telling me everything here now do i
automatically assume they're totally
guilty of everything i think they're
guilty of or is there something else
going on here you know
i i think china has not
part of being prepared in my world wars
ebook is is that is that um we have to
have a a world health organization
that's actually empowered to be able to
do things
it's just it's too beholden i think to
china and and there was a letter that
came out from peter dashik in february
of last year that he wrote in the lancet
along with a bunch of other people
saying
this thing you know
this is ridiculous to suggest that this
had somehow been bioengineered at a lab
meanwhile the internal emails suggested
that he had very different concerns
that's that's yeah that's worrisome and
i said that to p i said peter this this
is not making sense and what did he say
he said hey there's no evidence that the
virus ever existed in this lab there's
no evidence that at least that's because
they destroyed a lot of evidence they
they they it this is concerning they
deleted in how many how many
how much
evidence did they delete in 2019 i mean
some stunning amount well the entire
database went down exactly now i said
what i said to him you were part of the
who investigation did you see the
database now it's been over a year later
he said no when i said is that not of
concern to you he said look he goes it
was a public database they were worried
about hacking and and so that's why they
took it down i said if it was a public
database why were they worried about
hacking you know what were they what
were they trying to hide you know so
i don't i don't know joe what to make of
it it's the the there's clearly
as you said earlier i think you said
where there's smoke there's fire
probably but can i say conclusively no
and and part of me thinks we may never
know we don't have a system in place at
a at a sort of global level to mandate
that these things actually come to light
yeah we don't treat this like we treat
department of defense issues we don't
treat you know
we we should be thinking about this more
from a defense standpoint rather than a
a public health preventive standpoint
that's interesting yeah yeah
um when you see fauci being grilled by
rand paul and he denies that they were
doing gain of function research what are
your thoughts on that because by any
definition that was gain of function
research right gain of function research
is taking a virus we should probably
google the exact definition but
what my um impression is that gain of
function means you are
imparting
new ability to this virus to infect
humans right the idea is that you're
juicing it up and making it more
contagious that's right and and that
type of research has been done and in
fact i think it was done 2015 i think in
the in the netherlands somewhere but if
the nih was
was
giving funding to eco health alliance
and equal health alliance was
funding that kind of research i think
and then
is not being honest about that i think i
think the nih is clearly funding
eco-health alliance and eco-health
alliances clearly giving grants to wuhan
institute of virology here's how they
answer the question when i ask them
including francis collins who's the head
of the nih
they they define gain of function
research as this you have a known
bad contagious pathogen
and you're going to essentially
do it you know use the backbone of
another known bad
pathogen and you're going to splice them
together essentially
you're taking one thing that you know to
be bad and contagious and splicing it
with something else that you know to be
bad
that is you're expecting this to be
worse than what you started with
if you're taking a novel virus and you
don't know how contagious this is and
you're basically saying look i want to i
want to isolate the spike protein on
this new virus i'm going to put it on
the backbone of something i do know and
make it contagious to humans we'll see
how it behaves at that point does this
actually start to behave as something
super contagious or not
the the possibility is that it could
but they're not sure so this is nuanced
and you know a lot of people have taken
issue with it including scientists who
work in the field but the strict
definition is that you've got to know
for gain of function research you know
that it's going to lead to gain of
function so maybe the problem is using
the term gain of function yeah
if we instead abandon any sort of uh
nomenclature that might be problematic
and say
were they doing experiments to make
viruses more contagious to people
the answer would be yes yeah were they
doing experiments that could lead to
viruses being more contagious yes i
think that that's right
um that is that is research that is done
to try and figure out i mean it's a lot
of these pathogens they they examine
they're they're not contagious they put
the spiked protein and they put some
component of the virus onto the backbone
of a known thing and it doesn't do much
so they say we have to worry about this
but it could turn into a situation where
you take a component of a new virus you
put it on the backbone of a known virus
and it does lead to something
much more contagious and that's what a
lot of people are concerned about here
i mean you know there was the part of
those emails as you know joe were emails
that were sent to fauci in january of
last year where christian anderson
raised this concern he subsequently
wrote a paper saying hey
those changes that we saw i thought that
was clear evidence of bioengineering but
now i've seen evidence of those same
abnormalities in existing naturally
occurring viruses so now i don't think
that's that's the problem but it's just
it's it's going back and forth and you
know frankly we may never know for sure
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify